good morning Hank it's Friday and if
you're wondering why I just suited up
it's because I'm gonna give real advice
to real nerdfighters I'm already in
middle school hey congratulations on
graduating from fifth grade and I
haven't had you have an ID what your
first pimple your first night home
without a babysitter my first kiss what
is something wrong with me what and how
do I get it to happen what Hank there
were hundreds of nerdfighters from the
age of like 12 to the age of like 23 who
said I haven't had my first kiss is
there something wrong with me listen
there is nothing wrong with any of you
at some point you will meet someone who
you want to kiss who wants to kiss you
and you'll kiss them and it will be
disappointing and in all probability to
tonguey
what is the problem with us you don't
even get to be 12 anymore before your
life is incomplete without romantic love
how do I get my mom's pet rat to like me
I don't agree with the premise of your
question I smell everything I touch is
that weird
no that synesthesia how can I tell my
stalker off without hurting him so we
have this habit of overusing the word
stalker but let me answer this question
about real stalkers fixation is not the
same thing as love and you owe your
stalker nothing except for firm
boundaries and if he or she fails to
obey them a restraining order
my friend created an online persona and
pretended she was a boy and I kind of
fell for this fake boy and then when I
found out he wasn't real I was crushed
and I haven't talked to her since and I
don't ever want to should I Wow I mean
obviously I'm of the biased opinion that
everyone should read Will Grayson Will
Grayson the new book I wrote with David
Levithan but you really should I'm about
to graduate from college and I don't
know what let me cut you off right there
what you need to do is read David Foster
Wallace's brilliant commencement speech
this is water a link to which I have
conveniently posted in my pants I want
to meet some nerd girls okay first off
you probably should try to say that in a
less creepy fashion but if you want to
meet nerd girls let me recommend book
events actually for those of you who
live near Indianapolis I'm doing an
event with a la carte tomorrow Saturday
at 2:00 p.m. linked in the doobly-doo
and for those of you in Australia New
Zealand David Levithan my co-author is
on tour right now more info in the
doobly-doo I'm a high school freshman
and I have no clue what to major in in
college I don't know what to do with my
life that's because you're a high school
freshman you're not supposed to know
what you want to do
with your life now if you were a college
junior or something who didn't know what
to major in I'd be concerned I'm a
college junior and I just don't know
what to major in yes see you I am
concerned about however you are coming
to the worst possible person for advice
when I was a junior at Kenyon College in
Gambier Ohio someone called me and they
said you really need to pick a major and
I was like can you pick for me and the
person on the phone said well the
department's you've taken the most
classes in our English and religious
studies and I said okay then I will
double major in those honestly I think
majors are overrated I will remind you
that Hank green majored in biochemistry
and yet here we are you judging from
your video on Wednesday a rapper and me
a person who talks to blind soft puppets
in his basement
while wearing a Pizza suit I'm out to a
lot of my friends but my parents are
incredibly religious and conservative
how do I tell them their son is gay well
it's your life and you're gonna have to
choose when and how to tell them but
ultimately all you can do is be honest
but I will say that as far as I'm
concerned here being gay is not a
political or a religious issue and even
if you don't hear this from your parents
I think it's important for you to know
that there are many deeply religious
Christians who believe that being the
person who God made you does not and
cannot separate you from God's love my
dog eats all my mom's romance novels how
do I get her to stop
wait a second are we trying to get mom
to stop buying romance novels or are we
trying to get the dog to stop eating
them I can't tell because of your
pronouns ambiguous antecedent so Hank
that's my advice for the day pay
attention to your pronouns don't worry
so much about kissing and read David
Foster Wallace Hank in other news as you
know one of our favorite nerdfighters
Esther Earl is sick Oh Esther we thought
it would be nice if on Mass we all kind
of signed her guestbook to say that
we're thinking of her and we think that
she's awesome the link to do that is
located in my pants
peg thank you for getting what we tend
to say hello to me and thank you for
your amazingly good rapping I'll see you
on Monday